beaucoup de questions sur les audiences
ça baisse ça reste à sa reste ça bouge
en fonction des programmations
une fois ces bâtiments de redire ensuite
les jeudis là c'est le vendredi non non
c'est passé une fois
il ya un match de foot
alors je vous dit en fait n'importe quoi
redonner une âme à une instabilité de
programmation mais c'était toujours
devant nous et le 21 mars voilà mais en
tout cas ils sont inquiètes pouvoir 7 en
moyenne il dit sa fonction oui j'ai un
scoop
alors oui alors inscrit qu au sein de
quoi à qui alors j'ai plein de scoop qui
concerne de la nourriture la nourriture
est alors la nourriture vous me tourner
le perche de la trappe au vol et
j'enchaîne avec ce que je dois dire
maintenant puisque c'est vrai que le
métier ça se voit pas comme ça mais là
c'est du boulot vrai que le nerf de la
guerre ça reste la nourriture et c'est
là que je trouve ce vrai que depuis
quelques saisons il parle moins de
nourriture là ça revient il y avait un
choix à faire c'était est ce que vous
préférez avoir un coup de fil par un
coup de fil de vos proches ou alors un
bol de riz le choix a été fait cinq
kilos de riz à partir des visiblement ça
n'a pas plu à tout le monde
regardez dans l'intérêt de mon équipe
j'ai choisi le long terme mais j'ai pris
le risque
et on a dit tout sauf le riz qui avait
duré ou autre chose à manger
voici on a dit à manger le riz on a des
manques tu vas métal à rabat - une
équipe en fait il ne fait pas de pas
pour moi en comptant tous les jeunes moi
je n'en mange pas quelque chose je vais
peut-être un gamin je vais pas continuer
comme ça
j'ai pris de ma décision j'arrête ici la
voix et bondoukou devient bon il avait
d'ailleurs au passage mais qui pour le
riz quand même le riz bien oui maurice
ans c'est super important pour eux parce
que c'est des sucres lents c'est grâce à
ça qu'ils ont de l'énergie mais ça
constipé on lui dira que l'on t'a ils
ont pas plutôt le problème de
constipation mais plutôt demain ça peut
être très compliqué sur place alors
quand même une question que tout le
monde se pose et c'est vrai que ça
revient souvent sur les réseaux est ce
que oui ou non la production
nourri de façon insidieuse les candidats
alors j'ai l'info bah non comme on se
coupe vraiment novateur
y'a très cher non mais on va vous gardez
pour pour benoît dubois et puis on lors
de la saison 4
wafa de koh lanta que j'ai eu au
téléphone m'a avoué quelque chose au
bout de la 32e semaine donc c'est pour
des candidats qui était 2e jeu et maxime
daigneault femina et voix de soissons
que karen faye à chaud j'essaye de faire
un truc au bout du 32e journée quand le
plat c'était quand même allé assez loin
ils ont tous du droit un milkshake
banane c'est très important
voilà il ya eu une bronchite banana gris
ampera tueur le lait venait tourner tout
justement vous avez bien raison parce
que tous les profs des poteaux elle a eu
droit à un deuxième mitschek banane
comme les autres candidats et du coup
elle ça l'a rendu un petit peu malade
mais franchement c'était plutôt pour les
aider et ils sont très bien suivis par
des docteurs et ils ont senti que les
candidats étaient faibles donc c'était
plus dans leur donner un coup pouce et
pour que l'épreuve soit pas bidon et que
l'auris chéri mais j'ai un scoop la de
la couleur
la production est pas de candidates qui
date de mathusalem par nos
allez faites votre scoop donc 4e fatigue
le médecin peut donner après
l'unification un complément alimentaire
à base d'os de sucre et de bananes voilà
qui s'était mis à nu les mains d une
question qui se pose et c'est vrai
qu'elle se pose encore plus je sais pas
ce qui se pose est d'autant plus avec
s'est passé récemment la sombre affaire
avec comme s'appellent candidats en lice
en titane candide qu'environ hard candy
de renard les candidats c'est une fille
lui et la nuit et et ou pas toute la
nuit non non si la rachel raison
toujours mais pas trois passes et
mélanie mais fish ou quoi non j'aime
bien prendre
alors est ce que ces nouveaux ou est ce
que ça te sauter comme ça non ils
faisaient ça ça c'est pas nouveau ça tu
peux mettre basso si ça avait été filmé
la nuit aurait peut-être pas eu de
problèmes d'attouchements présumé pour
des cas d'intempéries quant à des
risques d'intempéries la wii mais sinon
ils n'ont pas droit
en fait les équipes partent à peu près
quand la nuit tombe donc ça peut être
très très tôt vers 19h dès que la nuit
commence à tomber peu tombé que tout le
monde se met sur son coucher et bien les
équipes s'en vont ils ont un petit os
qui en cas de problème ils appellent
auto qui disent ils s'en vont ils sont à
quelques centaines de mètres à peine
ainsi dire qu'en cinq minutes ils
peuvent rejoindre le camp sans aucun
problème
alors fait on va en parler de où sont
logés les équipes il ya une autre
question qui se pose souvent parce qu'on
l'a vu encore cette saison il ya des
départs puis ils sont éliminés puis
reviennent on va revenir sur
l'élimination de chloé et nous dire ce
qui se passe suite à l'élimination
regarder cet avant dernier bulletin peut
déjà être décisive
où
chloé chloé les aventuriers d'attributs
rouges ont décidé de vous éliminer et
leur sentence est irrévocable
mon équipe continue et je vous demande
pas et messieurs les coûts
ou d'aller jusqu'au bout
j'ai l'impression que l'émotion les
partager syrie là et c'est dur d'avoir
partir c'est un choix de raison
donnez vous à fond et il est toujours
une pensée pour moi on t'oublie peu
inquiète
merci beaucoup chloé qui est bien quand
il ya une élimination le candidat ait
émis à des zones denses à christine
oui absolument ils sont sur une île à
proximité
pas du tout dans un logement 5 étoiles
ans il sort ils rejoignent des équipes
de production sur dans un logement très
très très sommaire ils ont interdiction
de rentrer en contact avec leurs proches
même s'ils sont éliminés ou oui oui j'ai
une fois qu'on sait qu'ils ne
reviendront plus c'est à dire que ils ne
pourront plus bénéficier d'un abandon
médicale à ce moment là il rentre en
france
ce n'est que plus tard que les candidats
restent tous à l'hôtel ceux qui
composent le conseil final et qui à ce
moment là moi je critique souvent
l'émission mais il faut reconnaître que
dans ces cas là ils sont super suivi
nourriture il ya même un psy qui
s'occupe d'eux pour voir si tout va bien
et qu'il sera bit qui me vient comme ça
comment est ce qu'ils arrivent à garder
le secret parce que c'est tourné très en
amont ou sur le gagnant ballon et klose
y six mois on m'a dit qu'elle était un
peu d'effets il y avait des débris
carottes des cadeaux éventuellement
syrienne se disent assez fausse et ne
ménage pas si de l'argent dans le
contrat syrie après peu léger pour les
figaristes reçu pasqua le même sort à
lyon et à une fois que les votes ont été
établis il ya beaucoup il ya quelques
mois qui se passe entre la fin du
premier tournage et le reveal sur le est
évidemment et ce contact
il s'appelle ils peuvent faire leurs
estimations mais rien n'est moins sûr
concernant la véracité des propos des
uns des autres
donc en fait on n'a pas la réponse car
c'est beaucoup